the damage is is causing great damage to
anyone in fact he's causing so much
damage there's a joke in Israeli
intelligence saying that Ahmadinejad is
the best mole that Mossad has ever had
in Iran that in fact his name is it's
hawk he is a Jew a fascist drew from Tel
Aviv and he was put there as a favor for
the Israeli Foreign Ministry because
really he's the the the big the best
dream any Israeli diplomat could get he
is deaf or mating Iran every day Israeli
intelligence have reports about meetings
that Ahmadinejad had with allele orogeny
who was the Iranian envoi to discuss the
nuclear issues with the diplomatic
community with Europeans and basically
try to say we are not building a bomb
this is a a peaceful nuclear project for
energy and we are a peace-loving country
and he came talk manager and I said shut
the up please shut up you are
destroying everything that I'm trying to
do because I well I'm trying to say that
we are not going to attack anyone
especially not Israel you are saying
that Israel should be taken off the face
of the earth and you deny the Holocaust
which is like the most sensitive point
that Ahmadinejad could ever touch
I'm afraid of Ahmadinejad a person who
claims to have direct interface with God
a person who is positive that he saw an
aura every time that he addresses the UN
General Assembly and not just that he is
positive that everybody in the audience
saw the same aura makes me tick I am
afraid of such person yet he's not yet
the one in charge in in Iran the the
number one in Iranian hierarchy is the
is Ali Khamenei the supreme leader who
is in charge of what how does this
mechanism work I don't know and I don't
think that anyone knows it is very
different from Iraq of Saddam Hussein
where practically everything was
happening between his left and right
here in Iran would compete with the
complexity of its political system I
think only with Pakistan
and Iran is very hard to understand
nobody really understand what happens
there but at the end of the day this
regime continues to rule has no
alternative no competition not a likely
coming change regime and I would say
that Ahmadinejad what worries me about
him individuals is not affected there's
someone calls a manager that says these
things but the fact that he's allowed to
say as Medina jawed represent a big
faction of the revolution
he has his Ayatollah called Ayatollah
not a Geass D from comb which believes
that the Mahdi the Messiah should come
but only a very big Armageddon war which
means it's going to be much worse before
it's going to be better and there are
main parts chunks of the Iranian
bureaucracy and Revolutionary Guard who
supports him which basically suggests
that the Iranian regime is going to a
most extreme line
you